dude Ryan's the guy when you're watching
like Stand and Deliver he's like yo
teach is this unconstitutional
[Music]
so
um at a school in San Antonio Texas Nick
yep it's in San Antonio I know San
Antonio good tonight you do I've been
there for three days so I know it pretty
well probably more than you guys do now
I'm in there on Bunker have you been in
a river walk yep how come that's like
The Unsung city of Texas everyone talks
about Dallas Houston Austin because of
Spurs they're smaller but no one talks
about San Antonio they got an NBA team
you gotta be pretty big I went to that
Arena dude I was there isn't that where
the Alamo is yes it is it's really small
so small it's literally it's about the
Alamo yeah but yeah I don't really talk
about San Antonio like I want to move to
San Antonio then Charles Barkley have a
lot to say about San Antonio something
about their women oh big women the big
women in San Antonio yeah I don't see
that many big women in San Antonio never
saw the huge women in San Antonio
they're huge what is that even they're
nice Haagen-Dazs they don't have
Victoria's Secret in San Antonio I'll
tell you that black thought Victoria's
Secret caters to huge women now
do they yeah okay we'll check this out
mannequins check this out
so there's a school policy at a charter
school oh God that singles out students
who are on their menstrual cycle
okay why so check this out
you get a piece of paper and it's it's
bright purple
and if you need a bathroom break for
your menstrual cycle you have to use the
purple paper
oh man so you gotta out yourself to the
hole instead of just getting the
bathroom pass they need to regulate why
wait why so it's like teacher I need to
go to the bathroom they're like you're
gonna pretend like you're taking a [__]
I'm on my rag you son of a [__] okay
purple paper that's exactly what it is
so the problem was that kids yeah they
feel that kids were abusing bathroom
breaks yeah but then girls are like yo
I'm not abusing bathroom breaks
[__] I got my [__] going on yeah
and so they're like well cool will you
prove it call it out and prove it so
they want to make sure that they're not
doing that pulling that card every week
correct
this embarrass a [__] bunch of girls
that's what parents are mad about
because they say being a young lady in
this day and age is hard enough and I
just realized it was when I saw the
Barbie movie last month
my immediate thing is like that's [__]
up towards the kids but then also
thinking about how their school is
different from ours now I could see why
so let's say the bathroom breaks are
just a a cover for checking your phone
in the bathroom
so now imagine how much we all check our
phones between every break oh that's
true yeah now if all kids have phones
then it could be using that to abuse the
bathroom I can see that well dude
I mean we never abuse the bathroom thing
when we were in school never exactly
just to smoke cigarettes do we used to
tear that [__] up yeah I did but
sometimes I just had a [__]
that's true me too and you get a brown
paper to do to to go to the bathroom we
should have a yellow paper a brown paper
and a purple paper dude if you made
everyone we should have made it red
brown paper to go [__] everybody's like
oh my God I know that might be worse
than you've got can I get the yellow one
but it's gonna take a long time is it
like unconstitutional or some [__] to
just you can't use the bathroom and
class I feel like when I was in school
they were like no bathroom breaks just
like straight up yeah I remember you
have to ask for permission and then I
remember in college people just like
this and then you're like where's it
going yeah yeah they're like all right
he's an adult you can do whatever [__]
you want dude Ryan's the guy when you're
watching like Stand and Deliver he's
like yo teach isn't this
unconstitutional
it's unconstitutional and [__] I come in
with it with the Declaration of
Independence and [__] he roll it out I
love rights check it yeah I know my
right you never see he starts rapping yo
peep this manuscript never seen in
elementary school when kids would just
start going oh teacher emergency and
they're like about to die
I remember one time
um last week when you [__] your own
pants
oh much more further than okay okay it's
in second grade
my buddy Daniel was like
sure emergency right but it was almost
like time to leave like the Bell was
about to ring she goes Daniel settle
down we're almost about to leave he goes
no I have to go teach her I have to go
and then like she's like the bell's
about to ring right
and then right before it rings like he's
just standing there just starts [__]
going
oh no just standing there teacher yeah I
like to surrender he falls to his knees
congratulations
[Laughter]
get his hand up and he goes see I told
you I talked I told you and I told you
that I told you yeah it was so matter of
fact
the wind goes I I told you
I told you like jokes on you it's not on
him teachers get so weird about like
kids going to the bathroom for sure but
then like I I just feel like the stakes
are so low for them just be like just go
to the [__] bathroom everybody's
going to ask that's why they they don't
let you yeah but at the same time it's
always a lottery because somebody's
abusing it somebody always needs to go
like teachers have to really keep their
eye on slippery slopes that's true check
this out on this on this piece of paper
as well the paper's small and it's
purple and it also has a Shakespearean
quote from the sonnet 18. shall I
compare thee to a summer's day Thou Art
more lovely and more temperate it
actually says this on the bathroom why
what why would they put a coat there she
went on to say that so stupid well
that's what it says that's the
Shakespeare quote right yeah that'd be
sick if it said shall I compare they to
a Summer's Eve
it's like putting a random Bible verse
why it was the purpose I don't get it I
think it's just like you know it's like
they're protect their flower or some
[__] it's like weird [__] it's
inspirational for when you're on your
right weird [__] what grade is this
again
um it's a little bit weird if it's like
around the grade that some girls are not
yet comfortable with even talking about
yeah that's kind of crazy good point
like in in [__] high school girls
which is all about saying that [__] yeah
yeah you're like all right you think
girls mask their period stuff with
having to [__]
I'm so embarrassed on my period I gotta
take a [__]
I think at that age they actually would
they actually would I don't know which
one's worse I would assume like a junior
or a senior in high school would be like
Oh I'm on my period yeah yeah you know
what I mean yeah I think so I've seen
chicks do this like let's say they they
are on their period if they open their
backpack and I see them pull out a
tampon they don't open it and then watch
to the teacher hey can I use the
restroom they'll like kind of like put
it in the purse or they'll cover it
somehow because that's how embarrassing
it is yeah so they'd rather be like use
something else to disguise that they
have to change that's why they go I
gotta take a [__] please let me go that
is way worse if that's like earlier on
yeah so school's pretty proud of
themselves they're like they're having
themselves on the back and they figure
it out they released a statement that
was like Hey look to protect our ladies
from being limited by the bathroom
procedures we created a system for our
students who are experiencing the
menstrual cycle to access the bathroom
nurse and Supply sufficiently we only
ask that they use it responsibly so
they're saying like yeah this is tight I
wonder whose idea this was if it was a
dude's idea if it was a ladies idea
I guess it would be fine if they if they
asked the students and they voted and
they were like we all don't give a [__]
that's a tight ass system yeah then we
look like idiots for being outreached
for them yeah yeah this is I like big
outage for everybody though I remember
um me and my friends wanted to like hide
behind the bushes and smoke cigarettes
and then we're like what should we do
it's like all right
at this time when we get into class I
have to go to the bathroom all right and
then we all kind of asked at the same
time and we met each other up and jumped
behind the bushes and smoked a cigarette
dude I would do that with my girlfriend
I'd be like wait till the 30 minute Mark
and then let's just go we'll go to the
bathroom and then we just go like make
out real quick yeah but it's got to be
from a different team dude
they won't let you go simultaneously at
the same classroom no but we were in
different classes yeah see that's how
you do that's the truth yeah synchronize
it yeah you look at the clock and you're
like all right when it's up to 30. I'll
see you there [__] damn almost
I'm such a guilty Catholic so like the
for the five minutes before it hits 30
I'm going like
yeah yeah exactly it is yeah setting it
up setting the temperature long game
longer I think I think I do need to go
actually yeah yeah I was trying to fight
it but do a couple of half walks half
walk up to the teacher
I'm not ready I'm not ready it's still
it's still cooking Fun's still in the
oven did everyone go to the nurse's
office to go take a [__] back in the day
I went to go like have a straight up six
hours of sleep yeah I remember taking a
nap yeah oh really if I didn't if I
didn't sleep all night I would just be
like yo I don't feel good and I'll just
go to the office and just be out the
whole day at Mark keppel they're in the
nurse's office there was like two like
table things
and then she would just be like okay
just lay down and I just like lay down
and I'm just like
just knock off like the whole hour
the best thing about being a kid too is
you can sleep anywhere yeah like in any
anger not fancy yeah it's not a big deal
you don't wake up and go oh [__]
oh if you if you sick did they just send
you home or like do they still have the
nurse's office
oh with like a covid protocol yeah oh I
don't know because I remember all the
kids went to the nurse's office to take
a [__] because there was actually a door
there
that's a little buddy yeah that would be
you guys remember the [__] pink sand
soap oh yeah it does me and you're like
oh this is [__] great like cuts off
all your [__] skin yeah it like
exfoliates you like way too hard yeah
that [__] was crazy I feel like that was
the same [__] in the urine okay just
like ground up
made it sudsy
oh
[Music]